[Music]
talk about something is one of those
behind-the-scenes things that happened
on the show Kelsey Grammer was on this
program Monday night and we got a lot of
response from viewers this is all real a
lot of viewers noticed something during
Kelsey's interview here's a still from
the interview and if you can tell we
didn't do anything to this photograph
but he came out of his incredibly orange
hands can you get tighter on that can
you get tighter on that yeah look at
that yeah just his right hand yeah the
weird thing is like he came out and I
don't know if you I noticed an immediate
notice it right away and I thought I
disease hepatitis you know is he is he
ill I didn't want to say it wasn't
germinating seeds yeah thing is that
pollen I don't know what it was so we
were a little we didn't say anything but
then we got all of this attention you
know people were writing in to us fans
that really watch the show carefully say
what the hell is going on tell us his
hands so we asked around
turns out he's fine what some people
told us backstage some interns and
producers said that he was eating this
is all real we have cheese popcorn for
all of our guests who were on the show
and he was eating the cheese popcorn
with his hand and it got all over his
hand when he came out he was using a
distinctive three fingered style at the
picture and you can see he's got the
three fingers and you'll see there he
goes
the three fingered prong yeah it's
actually in the commercial break our
makeup people brought him out a like a
towelette but with no explanation and he
just kind of went I saw him he didn't
even really even realize that nose well
he licked most of it off during the
interview but you know what the thing
that's got me thinking you'd think that
we as a show we've been doing this whole
for a while I think would have learned
our lesson you know cuz we've had these
problems before there was the time that
we left baby back barbecued ribs and
Eric Stonestreet stressing around that
one I didn't know yeah there was the
time Kate Beckinsale had we just gave
her spinach bb-because she came out she
loves ya edge and then there was the
night matt LeBlanc was on we never
should have had a pie-eating contest it
was just a mistake eventually he looks
like he's a zombie
yeah it just ate someone's yeah I was
Joey Chomp
[Laughter]